celui que je vais l'accueillir
maintenant été relancé par laurent
baffie
il ya une quinzaine d'années aujourd'hui
il anime sur france 2 une émission qui
s'appelle dansez maintenant
il sort un disque qui s'appelle dansez
maintenant on va danser maintenant avec
dave
quel bonsoir mon épouse on sait qu'ils
sont derrière moi mais il y en a qui
prennent un bon mot ce côté là donc vous
des bruits commencent déjà déjà il te
tend une perche là franchement on a dit
qu'on en parle que d'être qui arrivent
en disant je m'excuse pour ceux qui sont
derrière moi déjà sait fort bien comment
ça m'a réveillé bon alors dave on va
faire un petit peu de promo apprendre à
parler de vous et puis après on va
revenir à la promo d'accord on va faire
comme ça alors là on y va tout
monsieur dave sur une compil qui
s'appelle dansez maintenant
il ya quoi les chansons habituel mais là
il ya vraiment calé que les plus grands
tubes des voix la plus in inédit qui est
plus haut inédit qui est jezebel et on
va écouter d'ailleurs que très bien
est ce démon qui vole mon coeur dans une
qui s'achève leur manquerait de richard
mois
j'ai un tube énorme set j'ai des balles
qui a été ces chars le limbourgeois café
les paroles de faire pour réussir car de
frankie laine sentais pas parler des
piastres guitare très espagnols disent
assez vite mais vite la compil donc
absolument pas sur tout nouvel album fin
janvier avec que des inédits là pour le
coup deux chansons nouvelles c'est
laquelle on et moi on n'a pas osé le
sortir maintenant il est plus ou moins
près mais on s'est dit on va être écrasé
par tous les gros machin qui sortent
donc on a préféré retenir et voilà c'est
des raisons purement bassement
commerciales bien alors dave on va
parler de vous on va parler de l'osé de
votre vie un petit peu parce que tout le
monde connaît de vous le côté très
joyeux comme ça très en essais selon les
plans initiaux
moi j'ai là plombé tout seul vous êtes
né à amsterdam déjà
non j'aimerais montrer un côté de votre
vie que peu de gens connaissent
finalement c'est le début de votre vie
vous êtes né on peut dire l'année de
votre naissance des en 1944 le 4 mai
votre vrai nom ses voûtes earl event bac
votre père était prof d'anglais votre
mère était danseuse et alors ben il ya
eu tout de suite de graves problèmes
évidemment pour votre père pendant la
guerre parce qu'ils étaient juifs
votre mère elle ne l'était pas mais lui
l'été et finalement vos parents ont
beaucoup souffert pendant pendant la
guerre au départ ils ont été affamé
pendant le fameux hiver de la faim en
hollande ils ont beaucoup souffert de ça
non mais ça veut dire que en land on a
laissé les juifs qui avaient posé une
longe tranquille jusqu'en 44 et tous les
patrons la bac s p500 quartz a décidé
que même ceux qui avaient montré la
bonne idée de pousser donc des goyim et
chic c'est véridique
aussi fallait les gaz et est donc là mon
père également s'est caché ma mère était
seule et veut rien à bouffer dans les
grandes villes sur toile sur dame donc
en effet j'ai commencé ma venir manger
des oignons de tulipes manger des
oignons c'est ce qui donne un digestif a
cédé pas un scoop ça c'est un scoop et
donc votre père ce qui était terrible
comme situation parce que votre père
était caché par les parents de votre
mère et votre grand mère était quand
même un petit peu antisémites ont pas
antisémite comment lutter à l'époque
c'est à dire ça je lui fis du peuple une
femme du peuple
oui mon père décédé sur le coup sûr
qu'elle n'était pas juif était par
définition du smic
c'était le cas de notre grand mère dans
votre père était caché par sa belle-mère
qui n'était pas un saint il était juste
un petit peu juste un peu comme si les
gens là ne pas lasser ça donc votre père
très courageusement refusé de porter
l'étoile jaune pendant là pendant la
guerre et rien n'est pas donc est alors
votre tante est parti aux usa avant la
guerre elle est devenu président d'une
organisation sioniste international de
femmes et à 14 ans un bon voulez vous
aller en israël vous installer dans un
kibboutz
j'étais très idéaliste vrai voilà
j'étais j'y suis toujours croyants et il
me semble que bref disons que je me suis
penché un petit peu sur différentes
révisions possibles et à l'usaid il faut
pas y aller aujourd'hui en tant que non
juifs puisque volière n'était pas
jusqu'alors beaucoup de problèmes en
israël il faut pas y aller elle a raison
en fait votre père était protestant et
après la guerre malgré tout il
s'offusquait beaucoup vous passiez par
l'allemagne par exemple pour l'heure
l'italie mais le même temps disait oui
ça horrifiés des savates j'ai une
voiture allemande voilà quand il le
devait arriver chez lui avec une
mercedes son père l'engueuler stew 1
c'est vrai c'est votre mère aussi été
très méfiante parce que même très
longtemps après la guerre elle parlait
des [ __ ] en 3d mais fun comme andy en
hollande et en baissant les yeux comme
ça l'un des siens lave a surtout l'air
autour d'elle elle regarde autour d'elle
oui il aura quatre ans beau père et en
protestant vous à l'école du dimanche
comme chez les protestants à c'est une
espèce de une sorte de catéchisme et
alors là tout bascule tout parce qu'ils
n'ont pas encore des banques à des
flashs sur une femme pasteur à quatre
ans non non elle avait 14 ans pour 14
des flashs sur une femme pasteur on
plonge très belle femme pasteur et et
vous commencez à devenir très croyant
vous idolâtrez dieu vraiment quoi vous
être je n'étais je les suis encore à ce
moment là je voulais devenir pasteur
parce que je trouvais 2 me par que ça
donnait beaucoup passe temps c'est ce
qui m'avait surtout plus cet écran tel
parce qu'on veut le vendre par l'est les
autres écoutent est donc comme j'avais
des années consenti ce bien ou c'est
naturel dit rien tout le monde vous avez
vous quand vous avez vu segovia
amsterdam après ça vous a fait le même
effet parce que très rapidement d'élèves
a compris qu'il était fait pour être
dans la lumière c'est vrai
what i croit alors vous priez toujours
vous avez déclaré il ya quelques temps
dans un talk show en hollande on vous
demandait quand est ce que vous aviez
prier pour la dernière fois vous avez
répondu quoi j'ai répondu ça me donnait
beaucoup de chantiers mais c'est
pourtant vrai que je
prie le paternostre qui s'appelle ne
vient pas comme ça quand j'ai bien joué
voilà c'est vrai qu'il serait bon il
répond elle à l'interviewer de
télévision hollandaise
je prie après avoir joui ce qu'a fait un
scandale évidemment alors à cette époque
donc effectivement de votre adolescence
vous l'êtes pasteur mais vous allez en
parler un pasteur et qui vous le
déconseille pas ce que vous lui avouer
que j'étais attiré par les garçons à
vous et pas de chance avec vocation
parce que vous les emmenez israël votre
tante vous dis n'y va pas parce que t'es
pas vraiment juif vous voulez être
pasteur le pasteur voulzy tu peux pas le
faire parce que tel par les garçons pour
être pasteur
c'est idiot des tchèques ce ne sont que
des vocations jamais empêché les curés
tu vas être chanteur on devine y va
parce que t'es pas vraiment pas bon mais
c'est pas ça prouve bien donner quelques
années il a fait beaucoup pour nous a
vraiment vous pouvez coller l'oise mais
voilà là le jour le revival de dave on
en parlera tout à l'heure le revival de
dave est due en grande partie à
l'origine est il de moi je mets de
l'argent de côté pour ma retraite
alors vous tombez au lycée vous tombez
amoureux d'un garçon les choses se
précisent et l attention il faut être
attentif au lycée vous tombez amoureux
d'un garçon mais ça paye and gertz
1 c'est ça hein et il est là ce soir
mais non mais non il ya un problème
parce que yann leur refuse
ouais liane gerd se refuse à vienne
alors effectivement vous découvrez un
jour je fais toute notre vie là c'est
pas bien c'est bien vous découvrez un
jour que votre père trombe haute mer
avec une jeune de 14 ans magnéto serge
simon c'est une petite orpheline que le
faire avait recueilli une petite
orpheline qui étaient bonnes au foyer
familial qui faisait craquer maintenant
mais bon c'est alors qu'on veut votre
mère découvre ça n'avait pas papa est
posée la bonne
votre père promet qu'il va s'arrêter
évidemment mais pas du tout la passion
était trop forte
tout ça ce ne sont que passion et
passion et ça continue jusqu'à ce que
c'est votre mère il faut quand même dire
qu'elle a épousé donc ce n'est pas une
sphère des trois ans il avait épousé
après elle a été acceptée par la famille
d'ailleurs la petite bonne là évidemment
une histoire d'amour une histoire
d'amour alors on peut rien faire on ne
savait plus on l'accepté bien entendu
bien et alors bon votre mère tombe
malade et cela il ya un fait très
important concernant votre mère là c'est
moins rigolo effectivement je reçois
dernière fois que le plan b l'émission
je rassure tout le monde sait que vous
avez vous étiez d'accord avec vos frères
et soeurs pour pratiquer sur votre mère
l'euthanasie ben c'est pas nous qui
l'avons fait heureusement mais disons
que ma mère de la demande et ça c'est un
sujet grave en effet qui est donc en
landes le tunisie est tolérée on n'a pas
légiféré à ce sujet mais tolérée et on
était tous d'accord puisque ma mère le
voulait
je suis lui après un livre je conseille
aux gens de lucien israël sur la déside
puis l'avoir lu d'accord du tout mais
c'est sa compétence était fait et ça que
je voulais dire sur disons qu'on était
soulagé oui on a demandé une autopsie
ont été soulagés d'apprendre que l'avait
les métastases de partout bien parce
qu'imaginez considère n'a finalement
c'est un peu trompé studio 10 ha non
c'est bon c'est là que vous avez vu le
livre du professeur israël vous vous
êtes dit finalement pourquoi alors
qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans ce bouquin
qui vous a fait dire que vous avez
peut-être eu tort de laisser
l'euthanasier votre mère c'est trop
personnel ma disons que je vais pas
parler de moi de ce que j'ai vécu parce
que c'est vraiment ça me regarde
par contre en général vous laisse pour
expliquer aux gens ce que ça peut donner
comme vice c'est à dire que vous allez
je prends mon cas ma soeur habite en
italie mon frère est en suisse moi je
suis à paris avait un frère encore long
on vient votre mère mourante
on arrive finalement non c'est pas là on
va on peut leur en fait quatre cinq fois
aller retour on ne peut pas ne pas se
dire elle va mourir elle ou quoi parle
dans l'optique story bladi donc si mme
laruelle pour le 10 mars nous un des
derniers question qu'a posée vraiment à
notre merci maman c'est pas ça pour nous
quand même est-ce que tu es sûr que tu
en as marre un moment mais demain ma
mère a regardé le ciel de sa fenêtre du
charme d'hôpital il y avait un avion qui
passait à lycée beau petit moment mais
soyons des missions puisque et mais
aussi on puisse quitte à ça pour pas de
partir j'imagine assez bon bref on va
pas parler tout ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas clair ouais alors là vous
partez amsterdam et vous commencez la
vie en face aux diables ou là dans le
cool c'est à dire que vous commencez la
vie les bars gay à amsterdam a le fiacre
et riche
oui comme ça c'est sympa je suis accro
aux essais libres avant enfin disons que
des vieux [ __ ] qui regarde qui regardent
des jeunes gens kerry pour la prime
tendance julia brin parce qu'ils ont une
certaine curiosité c'est un jean le
vieux coiffeur il était très vieux il
avait au moins 30 ans quand on a 18 ans
et vieillards et
il m'a amenée chez lui puis me fais des
tripoteurs ir une glace ou au plafond
donc il était vraiment vicieux et je me
suis regardé derrière moi et le mieux ça
va c'est pas [ __ ] donc c'est très
soulagé que le bayer dans le bon sens si
terre alors vous êtes un peu gigot à
l'époque quand même nom en je me suis
fait payer deux fois par semaine on
alors on ne sait rien il a 19 ans vous
rencontré votre deuxième mieux payés que
des fois parce que personne ne voulait
payer et l'ademe à 19 ans vous
rencontrez le deuxième grand amour de
votre vie après yann guerre ces lieux
sts et alors là vous acheter un bateau
et voilà mais la vie comme en non-vie
mais joue sur le bateau des sens de ce
que j'allais en france vous descendez à
ces sujets used actuellement si tu nous
regardes way dans sa chambre d'un
hôpital à villejuif et la cancer du
pancréas là et s'est dit bonne chance
donc là vous faites la manche un pari
sur la côte d'azur
c'est comme ça c'est là qu'on vous a
connu en fait ouais ouais ça c'était une
période extraordinaire
alors on 70 ans 66 je rassure nos trois
ans et année érotique c'est bon alors
donc oui il ya un problème avec joost
used ghost c'est le prénom déjà
ouais un produit comme les ramènent
toujours des conquêtes féminines sur le
bateau voulu vendre la moitié du bateau
eolas extrordinaire l'histoire c'est à
dire que day c'est à dire que used il
suit la côte en bateau et vous vous
achetez un mobile-home mobinautes et
davy suit la côte donc ils voient le
bateau dans la mer il avance pour pas
quitté un bien mais c'est beau comme
c'est beau ça se termine comme tout va
se terminer puis après bons termes et
après vous rencontrerez un jour un
troisième homme de votre vie et celui là
c'est le bon vous êtes toujours avec lui
et gilles ya un truc rigolo des découpes
marseille dont vous découvrez marseille
le hollandais qui descend à marseille et
vous faites jouer comme ça de la guitare
dans un bar gay le paradou qui
appartient la femme de mémé guérini
parce que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'à cette époque des ils étaient amis
un de la femme de mémé guérini à dijon
était proche des milieux c'est infini
voyez vidé après compte chez les voyous
les [ __ ] les gi's à chien dans la rue
oui c'est le monde est totalement
marginal à ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'à une petite [ __ ] eurasienne
qui s'appelle mouche et cette mouche
dirige aujourd'hui france n'importe quoi
c'est là tout l'enjeu de cette niche h
petit plus tard aliens elle tombe
amoureuse de vous elle vous propose
d'être son mac transit est histoire est
alors évidemment c'est vrai nom mais
j'ai pas voulu se faisant trop dangereux
j'ai toujours préféré être servis avec
ça et pas à auxerre c'est vrai et les
hommes de mémé guérineau vraiment
l'aider truand marseillais lui disent
attendre des venu on veut bien que tu
sois mac mais faut que tu arrêtes de
chanter parce que les matchs en temps
c'est pas notre truc
et puis après voilà bon pied prière vous
rencontré edi barclays qui vous signant
cinq minutes dès qu'il a dit qui vous
entendu et puis voilà et puis à la
carrière qu'on connaît
le trouver
je ne
pas mal
allez le faire
mais
et tout
et bah
j'adore quand il fait voir comment on
fait aller ça y'est wapiti wasquehal et
fo se détend didier
oui
mallat
si tu veux me soyez tu ne te mau arrive
bien
sous le ciel
et c'est selon
messieurs
je suis là
et
pas moi
je suivais
et toi et m'a conduit c'est plus
difficile
je t'écris
poker gueule
c'est par ici
sans le savoir tu
as et
tutelle
il est gay
non
m
je vous
oula
me
ça
j'ai pas vous
body
m
n'est ce pas là
jamais
c'est l'hôtel
bull pas descendre
non
merci bravo merci
hannibal faire peser africaine vous
pouvez poser votre micro maintenant il a
du mal à poser le micro mains danser
maintenant j'ai micro comme ça tout le
monde bien sûr puisque l'émission était
bien alors bien alors les années 80
fortes gelées disco porte un coup fatal
à votre carrière
non fatals parce que c'est un match que
vous n'êtes pas prêt ce que ça vaut bien
traversée du désert comme ont dit un oui
m'enfin quand même avec de l'eau un oui
ça a été le pire moment de ce traversée
du désert choix rouge et rentrer chez
moi à une heure du matin vraiment
arrivée la porte de mon appartement
enfin de l'immeuble
j'ai dit au jury personne m'a dit vous
chantez toujours à ce moment une voiture
de flics qui s'arrête et free couvre les
frais de leur débauche d'énergie qui
compterait merde ça venir chez les
folles courent d'elle c'est l'époque des
boîtes la province des galas minable et
du foire expo à metz pas finir à bord ça
peut revenir bien sûr alors voilà donc
vous revenez c'est vrai qu'il faut quand
même préciser ma fille fait partie de
ceux qui ont décidé qu'à un moment
certaines choses qui étaient ringards
devenez kitsch et avec force est restée
vide est branché quoi et c'est pour ça
que je me fais c'est laurent gbagbo
nous on applaudira été pour beaucoup
dans le retour de dave parmi nous en
l'applaudît marché
maintenant vous le savez c'est elle que
cela mais il faut quand même toujours
belge pour expliquer comment ça s'est
passé
sauf que moi je parlais tout le temps de
dev et un short il m'a dit dans pourquoi
tu parles d'edf qui l'y attend si je ne
fais pas qui va le faire oui un jour
c'est un musée d'invités dave et de a
été brillant et voilà et puis il était
bon à nouveau et sa carrière à
redémarrer tu ne dois tout accord et je
ne peux demander si ce pourcentage